A nuclear-armed North Korea, increasing aggression
from China, and space, cyber, and electronic
warfare are growing threats Japan faces in
a contested region.
Will Japan be able to maintain a solely defensive
military approach?
Guided by a seventy-year pacifist constitution,
Japan’s Self-Defense Forces (SDF) have never
been ordered into combat.
But for decades they have helped to maintain
global security.
Prime Minister Shinzo Abe’s cabinet reinterpreted
the constitution in 2014, allowing the SDF
to work with other militaries, including the
United States’.
In a 1960 security treaty, the U.S. pledged
to defend Japan in the event of an attack.
But U.S. overseas military commitments are
under increasing scrutiny in Washington.
And an ever-present challenge for Japan is
China’s growing military dominance in Asia.
Now, some supporters of constitutional change
think a stronger Japanese military is needed
to defend the country and would be an asset
to the U.S. in maritime disputes.
But the issue remains contentious.
Some Japanese citizens worry that the nation
will lose its pacifist identity.
One thing is clear: how Japan chooses to use
its military in the future could change the
balance of power in Asia.
Learn more about how Japan is reassessing
its military power.
Read Japan Rearmed by Sheila A. Smith.